if you guys are looking for like a wife
okay
um do you
would you guys want to date someone
who's a virgin
no
no no it doesn't matter to me i'm not
gonna lie really yeah
doesn't matter
not one bit so isn't it
isn't it interesting how
they always talk about how men value
purity and i and i think they do like i
don't but like obviously no guy wants a
girl that's been ran through but every
time i ask guys if they want a virgin
they say no why is that remember when i
said last time when i said i said
there's there's this unattainable
yeah woman
there's this unattainable pure woman in
a man's head
he wants her to know what she's doing
yeah it's a contradiction yeah it
doesn't say it's a contradiction i want
to know what you that you know what
you're doing
have you ever slept with a virgin
once i was a virgin yeah
yeah stayed away what
i think after that i
forgot to tell you guys
was that yeah was that just a one-time
thing no that what that you had sex with
that virgin well we lost our virginity
to each other oh okay i don't know yeah
what has it ever happened to you guys
where
it's you guys have done it once and
you're you're still
with the same girl
so my first relationship i
took her virginity but i had already had
sex before yeah we stayed together for
like six and a half years
okay yeah and then did the sex get
progressively better did she she started
doing things you're like wrong like
what did i teach
yeah you had to teach yeah i had to
teach okay but did she not do anything
to surprise you
no it was mostly on me yeah yeah did you
prefer that
no sometimes you want to be surprised i
guess do you know what i mean like you
want to be like
okay cool so oh you're doing that but it
only gets to there once you start the
teaching process you know what i'm
saying that once you start the teaching
process then they get confident enough
to do that because a lot of the time
virgins aren't that confident actually
do you know what i mean but you do want
like a sexually confident woman
but you also don't you see i said it's
unattainable but you also don't want a
whole
i i mean i had um
i have had a show
called who gets wifed up faster hoes are
prudes
fruits
it might be hoes you know is it hers
it might be hoes why
why because i'm a
i think y'all just don't know i think
it's going to be home
because i think like
i
i think that
um some girls have like mastered the art
of making a guy fall in love because she
gets really good and like bad yep
and
but i also think if you do it like too
much
then you know then i don't know but from
what i've seen
i've seen hoes get wiped up faster yeah
i think it might be hostile because they
probably know how to go after what they
want i think it's expensive
but i also think you guys like
prefer a girl that's like all in and the
hoes like what do they gotta lose
you know what i'm saying where the where
the prude will be like oh no
one month two months three months and
the guy's like f bad i'll just take the
girl who's gonna do it now honestly
speaking like if we lived in a society
that i think about if we lived in a
society where you know chastity was
actually like
um i don't know put on a pedestal
then
i'd want a virgin yeah but i'd want to
be a virgin myself yeah i think i should
know i mean so we can kind of explore
that together yeah
i
think i think the reason i would say no
now
is because of the culture of sex that's
right yeah
i think i think if you've developed a
certain
if you've had you've got a certain
sexual appetite
and
you've you know had enough experience
that you know what you like et cetera i
think it's dead it's very difficult to
go
back
because i'll be honest there's this one
girl that i dated a few years ago
that in terms of
everything that she was on paper
was like great was the most like
everything was perfect on paper
but the sex was the worst i'd ever had
the worst and it was mainly because
and it was not any bad thing but like it
was mainly because
she'd only slept with one person before
me and she'd only been with him for a
few months
so
she wasn't that experienced
and i know for a fact i tell you if i
met her when i was a virgin we probably
married with kids 100 yeah but it's
because of that experience of having
developing a sexual appetite and
everything now i'm like i can't chris
rock said it best he said women can't go
backwards in lifestyle and men can't go
backwards sexually
and i was like wait so what made it so
bad
uh but like make it youtube friendly
um what made it bad it just wasn't
i don't know the just
yeah the rhythm was awkward and like i
think
you know i think
there wasn't a it felt like there wasn't
a lot of um
effort on her part okay that's what i've
heard
that's that's what i've heard it's not
her fault yeah she doesn't know any
different do you know that's what i've
heard from guys is it's like they can't
stand girls that are like lazy in bed
and just want to like do nothing yeah
that's what i always hear
there's nothing worse than a woman
that's like lazy i'll be honest yeah
from my experience the most attractive
girls are the laziest in bed that's what
everyone says in the red pill
really you know what do you know why
london because they have not
they don't have to work to get together
yeah yeah that's what i'm saying the
pretty privilege kicks in is like well
i'm just pretty
come and get me and it's like oh yeah so
every guy she's been with yeah she's
trying to be put in the way trying to
put it
and she can't she don't know what to do
what about would you marry a virgin i
mean would you oh yeah i would yeah
yeah but i value um legacy yeah right
but that's like big for me but no i
really wanted to wait till i was married
i wish i did but i didn't
so would you so you wouldn't mind
so if you were at this point you've had
sexual experience and you found a guy
who was a virgin would you mind like
teaching him things
um
most guys have to teach guys anyway to
be honest
they have to teach them what they would
like because
i just don't vouch i don't think
like sex is that important like to be
honest like i just i think your values
is more important like
because i feel like sex can be learned
household yeah
so i get why you think that but i also
think do you think part of it is just
because being a woman
as well no that sex isn't important but
i think sex for guys is higher on the
value or priority list than it is for
girls there was a yeah i think there was
a there was a podcast with these two
famous american people i forget who is
there's a they're a couple
and
he was saying to her and it's like
seeing it have you seen it and he was
like
you know as a man that dead cast that
and he was saying listen you know as a
man that my sex drive is high and then
she was like well you know if i knew
your sex was going to be this high like
oh i know what it is
and i was just like but you got married
and he was like but you kind of coerced
me into this marriage it was like so
yeah so his argument was like
if you if you know that my sexual
appetite is higher than what you're
willing to give why would you enforce
monogamy on me that's what he said yeah
and she was like i didn't force you to
do it yeah and that was that whole back
and forth but yeah it's a really
interesting point yeah because he's like
well if he's he's going to want his
sexual appetite taken care of and you
you as my wife cannot do it so what do i
now do yeah but you'd be pissed off if i
went out and cheated right
so get your act together girl no i i i
said on one of the shows that i i think
that sex was a duty in marriage and
people were like did not agree at all
no i think it's a duty as a wife that's
what you're supposed to do my mom told
me i asked her because her and my dad
had been married like 30 years almost
i'm guessing and i asked her and she was
like i just say yes
that's why i have so many siblings
but the thing is as a man
generally
you don't want to know a woman's not
enjoying it yeah i don't know
do you know what i mean
she's not enjoying it i get what you're
saying and i don't
necessarily disagree with it entirely i
do to a certain extent i just wouldn't i
don't think i'd be
turned on by a woman who's having sex
with me because she feels it's her duty
yeah i want i want that desire to be
reciprocated and if it's not
reciprocated i'd rather not participate
yeah
personally how how often yeah do you
think
couples should have sex depends how old
they are
no i think it depends on your
relationship yeah it depends on what
your relationship is what we think
minimum
at least once a week yeah yeah you might
get at least i think that um
that's one of the reasons people cheat
sometimes is because the wife is like
holding out
mmm have you heard that
yes
yeah
like that when you said guys are either
monogamous or not monogamous i was
thinking earlier that i think sometimes
like men sheep because of like the
position they're sort of put in like the
girl like won't sleep with them hasn't
slept with them in months what do you
always say if a woman's think
sleeping with you she's sleeping with
because women like sex too yeah like
people act like only guys like this is
very true so if she's not sleeping with
you she's sleeping with you might have
to ask yourself that question you might
be getting from elsewhere bro
thank